Speaker 1: So let's spend just a few minutes on
Donald Trump and then we're going to move on to
Bobby Kennedy Jr and other candidates. As you
can see, this 2024 race is really filling out.
We're we're talking about Chris Christie and Ron
DeSantis and Bobby Kennedy. Biden and Trump is
interestingly, a relatively smaller and smaller
piece of that. I do want to play this clip for
you, Donald Trump. I mean, I feel so stupid even
saying this. Donald Trump laid out some policy
ideas yesterday in videos. Of course, he didn't
really lay out policy ideas. He basically ranted,
claimed he will do things he almost certainly
won't do and continued to tell the exact same
lies that he's been telling for years. We're
going to look at Donald Trump now announcing a
new health care plan. And I know that many of you
will say, well, but David, Trump announced that
his new health care plan was coming out two weeks
later than August of 2020. Don't you remember when
Trump said and I do remember that. I do remember
that. We'll look at that clip in a moment. Here is
Trump now, as if he hasn't ever commented on this
for the last six years and we don't remember or
how many years now, eight years, as if we don't
remember the fact that he's made these promises
many times. Trump says he's going to come up with
a new health care plan. And I know, I know, guys.
Speaker 4: I know when I'm back in the White
House, I will establish a special presidential
commission, really, of independent minds who
are not bought and paid for by big pharma. And
I will charge them with investigating what is
causing the decades long increase in chronic
illnesses. I understand Big Pharma, I believe
better than anybody else. Right. I know where
they're coming from. And then I will ask them to
publish recommendations for how every American
child can have a safe and healthy childhood.
Speaker 1: There you go. So it's going to be
another new idea of what we need to do on health
care. Now, you might remember that when Trump was
running in 2015 and 2016, he famously said
he was going to have a beautiful health care
plan to replace Obamacare. The only thing that
Republicans proposed in 2017 would have led to
24 to 32 million people losing health care. So
that didn't go anywhere. And then there was this
classic famous moment during the Chris Wallace
interview in 2020 where Trump said it was only
two weeks away from a new health care plan.
Speaker 4: Three and a half years. And
you don't have a plan haven't had excuse me,
you heard me yesterday. We're signing a health
care plan within two weeks. Right.
Full and complete health care plan.
Speaker 1: Yep.
Speaker 4: And the Supreme Court decision
on DOCA gave me the right to do so. We're going
to solve. We're going to sign an immigration plan,
a health care plan, and various other plans.
Speaker 1: We will be doing various plans within
the next two weeks. None of it ever happened.
And Trump is telling the same lie again. And
this really starts to get to insanity. How many
times can you fall for the same lie? What was
that thing George W Bush said? Shame on you. Fool
me once. Shame on you. Fool me twice. You can't
get fooled again. Something along those lines was
what George W Bush said. And honestly, folks, this
is just nonsense, nonsense stuff at this point.
If you believe, okay, now Trump really is going
to get the health care plan done, if you really
believe that at this point, it's sort of like I've
got a Brooklyn Bridge to sell you for a dollar,
that that's the level on which we're operating.